is anyone here like really like not
gonna shame you but do you not want
death penalty to exist at all yeah me I
think it's good that's cool they do the
firing squad style though where no one
knows who's responsible so you don't
have to live with that that's cool they
do without regards like make fun of each
other they're like I bet you did it
they're like
I'm sure you have to have a sense of
humor job like that man everybody
presses them you didn't the guy's still
there you're like oh if every button
still does something like yours will
just go
I just like so cool
Asian varieties
and then the one guy who's like hey
mine's not making oh
you should run a prison I think
I wrote a paper about it in high school
it was just like pick a controversial
topic and then argue about it the tax
dollars I was against it because of the
tax dollars because if if you have like
a a hundred year sentence and then
you're getting
every day so you're doing a sympathy for
the criminals yeah or or like the taxes
really okay